[Music]
cocoa beans are the primary raw material
for making chocolate they come from the
fruit of the Coca tree native to Central
and South America the ancient Mayans
would grind them up to make a special
beverage for marriage ceremonies and
other rituals today coca is cultivated
in the rainforest areas of many
countries in the tropics
these cocoa beans from Costa Rica were
cultivated without the use of chemical
fertilizers pesticides or fungicides
farming coca organically requires
meticulous care and maintenance of the
crop along with crafting techniques to
help establish disease tolerant tree
varieties
the farmer cuts a bud wood a young
Branch about to Bud from a healthy
productive tree and grafts it onto a
sucker growing from the base of a tree
which is either diseased or old and
unproductive
she cuts a slot at the top of the sucker
then wraps a plastic strip around the
bud wood to hold in moisture until the
graft takes
next she cuts a pointed end on the
budwood and inserts it into the slot she
made in the sucker
then she binds the union and covers it
with a plastic bag
ging protects the graft against two
potential extremes dehydration and
excessive rain which causes rot or
fungus
if the graft takes the union seals
itself in a month or even sooner
strategic pruning strengthens the tree
and keeps it growing low and in a shape
that's easy to maintain and harvest
[Music]
before long flowers begin to Bud
and Bloom tiny beetles pollinate the
flowers after which tiny pods the tree's
fruit begin to emerge
the pods grow and grow
[Music]
and gradually change color
[Music]
when the color transformation is
complete they're ripe for Harvest
there are many varieties of Coca trees
with PODS of different colors
It generally takes about five months
from first blooms to pod maturity
[Music]
come Harvest time they collect only the
pods which are undoubtedly ready
if a pot isn't fully ripened the cocoa
beans inside will be acidic and bitter
they carefully cut the Pod stem off the
branch without damaging the tree in the
process
[Music]
the pods rind is a little over an inch
thick it's rough and bumpy
they hack it open with a machete to
remove the fruit inside
the fruit is made up of a sweet edible
pop
encasing 30 to 50 large white seeds
these are the cocoa beans
[Music]
the beans and Pulp go to the
fermentation area where workers lay them
in boxes or heaps and cover them for
four to six days
as heat under the cover builds up
fermentation kicks in the natural sugars
interact with oxygen the pulp slowly
breaks down liquefies and drains away
the color and chemical composition of
the beans change and they become less
acidic and develop a chocolatey taste
the next step is to dry the beans
[Music]
workers spread them out on big trays and
lay them out in the sun for about a week
[Music]
here's what a cocoa bean is like wet
versus dried
[Music]
the dried beans now go through a
selection process workers examine them
removing pod remnants and any beans with
mold or other imperfections
beams which fail inspection are sold
locally at a lower price or go to the
compost heap beans that pass are weighed
bagged for export and sold to chocolate
makers
depending on the size of the beans which
varies according to the Coca tree
variety it takes about 300 to 600 cocoa
beans to produce one kilogram of
chocolate
[Music]